do you think there's some correlation in
terms of romance in terms of the word
you sometimes use Magic
is there some similarities in what
humans want and what roses want and what
nature wants I think so
I think there is and if I did not think
so oh my goodness this would not be a
nice world to live in I think
we all want love
I recently read this beautiful letter
that was written by Einstein to his
daughter
um and was discovered Einstein asked his
daughter to wait 20 years until she
reveals these letters and so she did
it's just one of the most beautiful
letters I've ever read from a father to
his daughter and the letter overall is
imbued with a kind of a a sense of
remorse or
maybe even feelings of sadness and there
is some kind of melancholy note in the
letter uh where Einstein regrets not
having spent enough time with his
daughter having focused on you know the
fear of general relativity and changing
the world and then he goes on to talk
about this beautiful and elegant
equation of E equals MC square and he
tells his daughter that he believes that
love is actually the force that shapes
the universe because it is like gravity
right it attracts people it is like
light it brings people together and
connects between people and it's all
empowering and and so if you multiply it
by the the speed of light you could
really change the world for the better
and I I call me a romanticist I know you
are too
um which is why I so love being here I I
believe in this I I totally and utterly
um believe in in love but let me just
excerpt from Einstein's letter there's
an extremely powerful force that's so
far science has not found a formal
explanation to it is a force that
includes and governs all others and is
even behind any phenomena operating in
the universe and has not yet been
identified by us this Universal force is
love
he also the last paragraph in the letter
as you've mentioned I deeply regret not
having been able to express what is in
my heart which has quietly beaten for
you all my life maybe it's too late to
apologize but as time is relative
that jokes to Einstein I need to tell
you that I love you and uh thanks to you
I've reached the ultimate answer your
father Albert Einstein yeah for that
regret I deeply regret not having been
able to express what is in my heart
maybe that's a universal regret
filling your days with busyness and
silly Pursuits and not
sitting down and uh expressing that but
it is
everything it is everything it is why I
love that expression and I forget who
said this but
I I love my daughter more than
um Evolution required right and
um I feel the same way towards
my other half and and I feel that when
you find that connection
um everything and anything is possible
um and it's a very very very magical
[Music]
um
a magical moment so I
I believe in love and I believe in the
one